hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 I'm Mike McCarty and
I'm gonna be here the rest of the day
with Lucy James hello and we are pleased
to be joined by Ghost Recon break points
Matthew a UX designer and grace
community developer hello you guys you
got kind of been periodically showing
off the game right I was actually at the
preview in New York a couple months ago
got to play it like 15 minutes not
enough but I was excited to play it
Ghost Recon breakpoint for those who
might not know give us a summation
before we move on this is a Ghost Recon
bang point builds on what we delivered
in wildlands so it's gonna put you in
the boots of an elite US Special
Operations Forces soldier but this time
you are behind enemy lines you don't
have the same support that you did
before you don't have a mission briefing
this time so you're really down to your
sort of bare skills and being the best
of the best that the US military has to
offer and this is the scenario that we
drop you in right at the beginning of
the game so I'm curious because I played
a lot of wild lands and you did update
that game really frequently you even
just did with the one that introduced
Jon Bernthal as kool Dee Walker the
villain but I'm curious how much of
break point to me feels as if it is an
answer to criticisms of wild lands and
wild lands sold really well people
really liked the game but break point
feels like it's kind of going where as
wild lands had this side that was like a
GTA a crazy GTA game and then there was
a side that was like more traditional
tactical stealth to me it feels like
break point is going more toward that
subtle kind of dangerous world side is
that accurate or is it more than that
what we wanted to do with gospel con is
really put the players in the boots of
his pickups and we wanted it all to
explore other aspects of it it's not
only about the shooting and it's not
only about the mayhem that you could
have in this type of game here it's more
about having other aspects like the
wounds that you can suffer from the
fatigue that you can have it so when
you're we walk a lot making sure that
when you go in the slopes you can fall
down if you go too fast or you can be
tiring if you go up you can spend time
in the beef web to prepare for your
strategy
so as you know when we work a lot with
consultants former spec ops and the
fighting aspects is only a small
percentage of that time and we wanted to
explore also these aspects of it super
curious to me also
so recently at the Ubisoft conference
during the ghost recon point you
announced there will be AI teammates as
of like two months ago the idea was no
this game is about being like a if
you're playing alone or if you're
playing with one other person that's
about being this lone or this duo that's
kind of you know struggling to survive
on this island that where you're the
hunted person what was the decision was
that a community thing that people give
you feedback how did you arrive at the
decision to bring those AI teammates
back actually it's really a
collaboration between our two jobs at
first the experience that we wanted to
provide is more lone wolf experience at
least in the terms of the narrative and
we wanted the players if they want to
play with the squad that is super
important in Ghost Recon to play with
other players online so that was the ID
and we saw that some players were bummed
not to be able to play with AI teammates
and that's funny because we added the
opposite reaction sometimes on violence
and we did a title update where you were
allowed to play without them but here we
saw that there was a very strong
reaction from the community and we felt
okay this is something that we would
like to explore also so as a title
update you will be able able to choose
between playing without team AI
teammates or paying with it because in
the end what's really important for us
is about the fact that the game is for
the community and we want them to be
really able to play as they want we want
them to have a real freedom of choice so
we are going to give them the freedom so
how do you I've asked this question to a
number of developers today actually it's
how do you kind of filter through that
community feedback because how do you
balance it against what the community
wants and what's feasible for you as a
developer like the community development
and myself more other than that I'm sort
of the conduit between the production
team and the community and vice versa so
the community to the production team so
obviously we have a lot of people who
have a lot of opinions and wallet's
feedback and
not everything can be implemented and
not everything should be implemented but
we definitely want to look at the larger
trends within the conversation and
really understand why people are either
frustrated or happy with like a certain
feature for example so we really work
with a lot of other teams to analyze
like the data it's really important to
us to be able to quantify this and to be
able to deliver that to the production
team and say here's what they're talking
about here's what they like use what
they don't like and you guys ask the
professionals as the game designers you
can make the decision to implement or
not implement or make adjustments or
course-correct
as because obviously you guys have a
creative vision and you're going to
execute that but you know I mean that
the players are stakeholders for us so
it's really important that we have their
collaboration and their feedback in this
process and it's a really one of the
great opportunities that we have now and
it's something that globally you just
have to really push our relationship to
the players and the fact that the game
is alive and we have lots of title
updates so we have a vision that we're
bringing and it's busy also possible to
make it evolve through time and that's a
great opportunity for us as developers
Ghost Recon is very different than it
used to be I mean in some ways it's
still it's still like Ghost Recon but
it's come a long way I think wildlands
was a huge departure obviously from
maybe the traditional format I it seems
like break point is like real is
reinforcing a confidence in what
wildlands started if that makes sense is
there a sense that this is kind of
continuing what wildlands started or is
this going back to older Ghost Recon
games where does it feel for us really
the pillars of Ghost Recon is the fact
that it's a military shooter obviously
and it's really something that we'll
never give up the fact that it's a club
it's something super important to us
because we have so great moments and we
saw people playing at the booth and even
if the game can be a bit gritty and the
mauryas oxide still you have the fun of
playing with your friends and having
some surprises and some amount we could
hear laughs so it's something super
important
and what we really like about the open
world aspect that priscilla keeping is
the fact that it leaves you lots of
freedom in the way you choose to explore
the island how you want to approach
different camps and it gives you a 360
approach where you can really build the
tactics and I think that this technical
aspect is really something also that
make us different from other games
speaking the tap tactical aspect it's
interesting to me that you don't just
get a waypoint on the opposite side
island they don't say hey just go here
you'll will tell you everything to do it
seems like you're letting go with the
players hand a little bit in respects to
getting to a mission or figuring out
ways to approach things is that accurate
I think it's something that especially
pleases our audience they'd like it to
be not always at hand all the other all
the time and we can ask them a bit more
I would say maybe on a gospel cam game
so they will be able of course to follow
a path that is easy to flow if you new
to the game and you're not huge and you
don't have you don't want too many
options but a same amount we also really
lets them from the very beginning of the
game go anywhere on the island there's
no linear part at all like at the
beginning with a series of tutorials you
will have them but you will be from the
very beginning where you play you can do
wherever you want and this freedom is
super important to us and so will
enemies level along with you as you're
going around or is it gonna be kind of
like blocked off depending on so there
is a the enemies have levels and
yourself you can find new gear that will
improve your level but it's not like
it's the same kind of RPG as you can
find any other games because here we are
still very player skill based the
players will see and that's what are the
experience for the play the demo it's it
has a very similar feeling to violence
where a bullet in the head eliminates
all human and Me's so you're they will
raise with you but it will be an
incentive to find some weapons because
they cannot be effective but we're
really your gear leveling shines is
against the drones and we are bringing
very deadly foes against the
the players it's more the mechanical
enemies and we have in the demo a very
big huge tank that is automatized that's
called a bear ma and you spend time
fighting against it taking down his
defenses finding the weak spots and of
course if you have a better gear it
would make your life easier
what was the thinking behind and behind
adding like a gear leveling system at a
loot system to be reductive whereas
wildlands had more of a go to this
specific crate for this weapon and you
get the weapon Smith and you can outfit
it that way but what was the what was
behind the decision to move toward this
more I don't know if I want to say
modern but I kind of like color coded
level leveling system so we realized
that even if wheels are really happy to
have lots of options in a game like
Weyland's of different weapons you don't
change it so much because they don't
have a good incentive to do it so here
we are bringing elements of progression
linked into those weapons even if in the
end what's really important are your
skills but it's a very nice incentive to
try different weapons and they all have
really a different playstyle and a very
different feeling and it helps you to
try different things and to try to find
out what you like but here we are sure
if there's a weapon that you really like
this is a very fits your playstyle there
will be systems in the game that will
allow you to focus of the weapon upgrade
it and even make sure that you can have
the right level for this weapon with all
the rest of your level slightly more
towards the campaign and obviously at
the years of press conference we had the
Punisher himself Jon Bernthal come on
stage dude I have a question about the
dog okay it's gonna be the game so this
is I can either confirm but Bam Bam was
great on the stage and I think we should
all remember the moments that we had
together which were beautiful that
sounds like a no to me men are the
moments I had speaking of the campaign
the game's name breakpoint
kind of derived from the idea that like
oh there's gonna be like mental
exhaustion on these spec ops soldiers
there's going
you know maybe aspects of their you know
their psychology coming into play you
know you're adding you're saying you
want to make feel like you are a SpecOps
soldier with the survival with the
tactics with the fact that you are kind
of cut off from everybody else video
games in general don't have the best
track record with depicting like war
like that obviously it's a video game
it's meant to be fun that's your
priority it's meant to entertain is it
difficult to balance that serious
subject matter with the more gamey
aspects of break point I think we'll
stay more distance on this topic because
we've discussed a lot with former spec
ops we know how of course that it's a
very serious topic here and we try to be
as respectful as possible so I would say
that the narrative without spoiling too
much is quite serious and it has a
different vibe from violence previously
but in the end what really builds the
experience is what you are doing during
the game and if you're playing with
friends of course there will be a
lighter tone where I would say that the
story of the game is the story that you
have it's what you decide to do it's
what happens with the surprises and then
here I would say that we are respectful
to it that we don't even like pretend
that it's possible to depict it in a
very totally realistic way but we try as
much as we can to be respectful and I'm
also curious we were talking earlier
with Patrice Nestle who's helped but
with his his team they're making
ancestors the humankind Odyssey we
talked about kind of the sudden
resurgence or the recent resurgence of
survival games and of course breakpoint
has more survival elements now what is
it about those that make a game
entertaining if that's dude is that even
the right word like why add survival
elements to these games when survival
itself is this really stressful idea
what I think is that the survival aspect
it can be really enticing because it
makes the things more real and I think
having a super heroes that are no never
wondered never tired it's not something
that you really believe and we wanted to
explore that not only to show the
moments of
weakness that you can experience but
also to show how you can shine and when
you are in full capacity when you're
fully rested and it's more a theme that
we're exploring here then I think like
your gameplay that can be a bit
frustrating I would say that we are more
in the appositive design aspect where
all these survival aspects will help you
become even better than you were before
awesome well unfortunately that is all
the time we have Matthew and grace thank
you so much for joining us we appreciate
it thank you are watching from home or
from here in our live audience
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
shortly after a break
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]